auf dem planeten zäher es wurde ein
mysteriöses quadrat entdeckt und das
ausgerechnet im orca tor krater der mit
dem hellsten fleck auf dem planeten
haben uns aliens ihre spuren
hinterlassen die wir nur mit
hochentwickelter technologie einer weit
entwickelten zivilisation entdecken
können ein nicht unwahrscheinliches
szenario klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen in 2001 odyssee im
weltraum nahm außerirdische genauso
kontakt zur menschheit auf nur da war
das mysteriöse objekt auf dem mond kann
es also sein dass eine hoch entwickelte
zivilisation so kontakt zu uns auf nimmt
die umstände dabei sind schon ein wenig
verrückt und wenn man sich diese
filmvorlage als orientierung nimmt
spricht vieles dafür aber es könnte eben
auch nur ein wunschgedanke sein und
fantasie die mit uns durch geht aber der
reihe nach entdeckt wurde series 1801
aber erst vor wenigen jahren 2006 wurde
er mit seinem durchmesser von rund 900
kilometern in die gruppe der
zwergplaneten eingeordnet ein jahr
später am 27 september 2007 wurde die
sonde dawn führt er es geschickt erst
acht jahre später erreichte sie cs am 6
märz 2015 seitdem schießen spektakuläre
bilder von cs und hat den zwergplaneten
inzwischen komplett kartografiert
bereits am 13 januar sendete die sonne
ein rätselhaftes bild an die erde
sie hatte einen extrem hellen weißen
fleck entdeckt der sofort die
aufmerksamkeit der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen auf sich zog fast
ein jahr später konnte das rätsel der
flecken im krater gelöst werden aber die
lösung macht es nicht weniger mysteriös
zum einen stellte sich heraus dass es
mehrere flecken waren und diese licht
aussenden beziehungsweise sonnenlicht
reflektieren was das spektrum von
mineralsalzen wiedergab genauer hydra
visierte magnesium sulfat aber noch
spannender war ein anderes phänomen in
krater schwebt ein dünner nehme das
forschungsteam schließt auf
verdampfendes wasser perfekt also für
eine mission mit menschen zu dem
zwergplaneten doch dann gab es eine
weitere sensation die nasa hat die
mission inzwischen mehrfach verlängert
und schwenkte die sonde inzwischen auf
eine elliptische umlaufbahn ein vorteil
ich kann jetzt viel dichter an series
heranfliegen und dabei entdeckte sie
etwas ziemlich verrücktes am 22 märz
2016 überflug dorn den zwergplaneten in
nur 385 kilometern und entdeckte in
einem hellen flecken dem vinalia
fakultät eine quadratische struktur
einerseits etwas das auch durch zufälle
in der natur gebildet werden könnte aber
andererseits eine ziemlich mathematische
struktur es wäre ein symbol das genauso
wahrscheinlich außerirdische zum beginn
einer kommunikation verwenden würden und
jetzt gibt es noch bessere bilder die
die sache nicht besser machen denn zum
einen ist das quadrat nicht perfekt
quadratisch eine ecke fehlt quasi aber
beim genaueren hinsehen sieht man ein
zweites quadrat in quadrath etwas
dunkler und das ist ziemlich perfekt es
bleibt also spannend und wenn der
irgendwann in der lage sind das quadrat
näher zu untersuchen
dann könnte es vielleicht das tor in
eine andere welt sein oder eine große
enttäuschung also wenn er kein video
dazu zum beispiel und zu anderen themen
verpassen wollt auch extra videos
spezielle livestreams und so weiter dann
werdet mitglied die auf dem kanal und
nehmt noch ein paar privilegien mit
außerdem unterstützt er uns mit einem
kleinen betrag einfach mit wild werden
also direkt hier unter dem video
draufklicken und vielen vielen dank an
alle die das schon gemacht haben wenn er
immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endlich bei
whatsapp dann umgeht denn die etwas
unzuverlässiger aber ob sie auf youtube
und er verpasst kann video einfach hier
draufklicken und hier
da geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt
bis dann bleibt dran